how many reps can you do with that 225
like 20 22 25 is more than twice my way
I'm here ups good you do with me it's
all careful looky look Oh
no you don't okay nobody parties but me
yes and we party no yeah just rob yes
and me no I'm the only one who parties
I'm pretty sure I've partied before no
Kevin I know for a fact you don't party
okay you do not party good Kenny out no
we man was so we can't up in the side to
sell weed the little drinks nightlife
dancing throw a huge party I mean huge
party everybody's invited women
everywhere only 7 francs because the
ticket machine was broken
doctor hang of the Metro took it
everywhere when to afford model party
hooked up with a Romanian model named
Karina she sucks my [ __ ] at the
Marriott's on Thursday which is good
when shopping at the cheetah me mano a
Ferrari the quad remember the Saudi
royal family made out with a Dutch model
in front of the Holly artistry often
almost became roadkill for us in the
street I think we have to go all out I
think this situation absolutely requires
a really futile and stupid gesture be
done on somebody's put we're just the
guys to do it
let's do it
news for you pal they're gonna nail us
no matter what we do we might as well